today's topic got this video from a
jubilee
what is shax
like for men are you afraid to do butt
stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
how often do you actually think about
sex i would say i think about it
like a couple times a day once you've
had sex it just
naturally crosses your mind i think not
like consistently but like
it'll pop in when i was a virgin every
single hour of every single day after
that maybe once a day
my man you dress like you trying to be a
virgin again
this man dressed like you joined the
nation of islam have you ever
seen the wire no you don't know about
the brotherhood
well how often do i think um listen up
until a few years ago i think about it
like every day multiple times a day
like i don't know what happened once i
hit 30 but i was just like i don't think
about it that often what about you
no i don't yeah yeah it's just uh it
starts to take a bit of a back seat you
know what i'm gonna go a step further
i'm gonna say
i never really thought about sex that
often what i thought about was
getting with girls does that make sense
it wasn't
it wasn't like i need to do it because i
want to be able to get there just
design so it's a bit of a different
thing because if i want to i could just
have the same person kept doing it with
them all the time
but i didn't want that no it was you
know yeah yeah
quantity yes get them yeah get a girl oh
you you want me to
okay let's go
yeah no yeah it's it takes a
it takes a backseat at some point yeah
yeah not as much as when i was in my
teens when i was in my teens
yeah no no everything was
the the wind sexual [ __ ] the ac
sexual everything was sexual bro the
first time i shaved my head and i felt
the wind on my head
on my scalp i had an erection i said oh
why you touch me like that
excuse me yo stop playing
yo why what you doing what you trying to
do when
what you're trying to do mother nature
bro stop playing
bro you know what i'm
saying i got touched by chris breezy you
know what i'm saying
oh listen i'm gonna go even a step
further
if you don't know because you've never
been touched because you don't like you
mean man my hair was [ __ ] when i was in
cadets
just because you felt the long goal
doesn't mean you don't know you got to
feel it again as a grown man it's a
different thing
you know what i mean because now you've
paid your taxes you're a contributing
member of society
the breeze touches you you're just like
i earned that you're just talking
nah nah bro i'm telling you i'm i had i
had long hair for a long time bro
i shaved it and then i felt and i was
like and i remember
i could wear hats again it changed my
life i can't wear hats
not now not then either
i had big big [ __ ] you don't even
understand
how big this is that's without the hair
bruh i'm talking about it you didn't say
what i was saying
i got it i was premature i came out
eight eight pounds
my mama started my mama stopped bleeding
last week that's a big headache
i'm telling you bro bs hey wind on your
scalp is a
game changer i'm gonna also say this
most of my time like i didn't think
about sex but
i went at it like every day i was just
like i hope so
and i just got so excited that's how big
my head is you see the label how much x
how much x is that
that's a lot that's five x's that's
that's a correct five x that's a crazy
porn video
that's so crazy
get your own netflix show i'm super
ahead
today's video is sponsored oh wait all
right you already know
okay we're ready today's video is
sponsored by blue chew say it with us
now blue chip it's time for you to gain
more
confidence and longer lasting
experiences in the bedroom with
bluetooth tablets okay
you deserve better she deserves harder
bars listen blue chew
is a unique online service that offers
you
the same active ingredients as a viagra
in cialis but in a chewable form and at
a fraction of the cost
and one of the best parts is that you
know bluetooth it's an online service so
you don't need to go to the doctor and
have an awkward conversation with that
person
all you got to do is go to bluetooth.com
you just need to consult with one of
their medical licensed professionals
and once you're approved we just ship it
to your door and we got a special deal
just for you guys
you can try bluetooth for free when you
use promo code abba
all right and all you gotta do is pay
for the five dollar shipping that's
bluechew.com using promo code abba and
get your
first month free when did you lose your
virginity how was it
for a long time i actually thought that
i had
really really young onset erectile
dysfunction
i had like this incredible anxiety when
it came to sex
and so every time there was an
opportunity to have sex it just
my body was not on the same page my body
my body say no
my dick didn't work the same just say my
dick didn't work it's okay
we've all been there i've had an
experience like that oh of course there
was actually one person in particular
who i'll never forget
but she was like laying on this bed and
she was like wow you have a naked woman
in front of you and you
and you can't get hard you know there
was just a flood of like all like
the feelings of like inadequacy you know
the interesting thing about moments like
that is like
sometimes ladies get like crazy like
what you got woman from your kids like
what did i look at you like you can't
get a man hard and blame it on you it's
like
sometimes it's not one person's fault or
the other
sometimes it's just a compatibility it's
our duty i've had
i know ladies who can't orgasm if
they're too stressed out
that's most ladies by the way okay now
would i be like
so what i'm doing all the right things
and you can't bust no it's like
sometimes your mental's not there
right sometimes you aren't that
comfortable around that person it's not
a reason to shame them so
just be mindful that if you meet a dude
who's going through erectile dysfunction
it's not for you to be like
something's wrong with him sometimes
there's no compatibility or he may just
be going through some form of anxiety
and you need to be patient with that
like guys go through erectile
dysfunction at some point it's not
erectile dysfunction we go through
phases where
you know [ __ ] don't work the way it
works but women
most women don't orgasm most women
do not orgasm it's not your fault it's
the way it is
it's the way you you're not in the you
know you're not
you're not in the mood you're not in
there's a lot of things that you think
about because of society and stuff like
that you know what i mean
you have to make a girl at ease ease for
her to be able to you know
that's not one time a year yeah and all
that i had been thinking was going to
happen
negatively in my sex life did happen in
that moment
do you get emotionally attached to girls
you have sex with
i was like a late bloomer like nothing
in high school and then like after high
school
and in the college then my girl started
paying attention to me so i was like
i could care less about being
emotionally attached it was like any
girl that i was
mostly attracted to i was like great
awesome you know
you maybe kind of suck as a person but
like oh well like we'll figure that out
later
i'm just happy to be here
that's most dudes inside a vagina i'm
just happy hey
look at this look look at that look at
this this is so nice and cozy
you imagine you're inside a girl she's
like so how is it i'm just happy to be
here hi
thanks for having me
like you're running a cheap hostel and
someone's just glad to have a bunk over
their head
how much do you understand the female
anatomy down there can you name
all the parts right now down there i
mean you don't have to know the names to
really understand it but
you got the labia the majoris labia or
whatever it's called the the hood
then you have the yo you got the hood
son that's what it says yeah i mean then
you got the click
you got the outer lips the inner lips
which is the labias i was mentioning
right then you got the urethra [ __ ] i'm
saying that you got the sugar walls you
know what i'm saying the good she went
with right then you got the gooch
the gooch is very important which is
prime spot the prime spot the grouch is
like the
the the land between north korea and
south korea it's like a no-go zone you
know what i'm saying it's where the
treaty happens between
no gooch clowns no goose
they know about it
ladies ladies if you're not gonna go
down to north korea okay we'll still be
very appreciative yeah
rub the goats rub the goose the gucci is
a disgusting word
gucci
yeah but you know exactly what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
what do you mean the gooch oh yeah isn't
it just one thing
no it's not just one thing there's a lot
of things attached to this
one thing yeah
can you describe how it feels to
ejaculate does it feel like peeing
okay i'm gonna drop some game on you
guys all right there's three levels of
orgasm okay this is straight from apa's
academy of bro science
level one orgasm is the one everyone's
familiar with right you watch porn
boom feels good real quick move on with
your day you have regret instantly
afterwards you feel better
okay then you have level zero those are
the ones where you're trying to bust
and then you for some reason [ __ ] it up
something comes out but you don't get
any of the dopamine effects
so then you feel really depressed
because like not only did you bust it up
but you didn't even get the benefits
it's like um
but then there's level two this is
magical this is um
somebody's gotta pull it out of you okay
you get this from edging a lot or from
when the girl goes down on you you know
what i'm saying
you get the tsunami alert then you brace
for impact then you unleash
and sometimes it can almost feel like
you're peeing but you're not amazing
level two
highly recommend it anything you want to
add the first time you know
it's like you you know when you've been
under the water for too long
you've been under the water for too long
and then after that
you just gasped for air the first time
you nut whoo it's it's like aaron
like you're trying to have that high get
back to that first high
but the first time you busted yeah i
would say the only time it feels like
peeing is like when you're holding it
for a really long time
and like you're trying to get to the
bathroom and then finally you're just
like oh
do you care if your partner doesn't
finish yes
everyone should care oh my goodness ah
this double standard frustrates me to no
end
i feel guilty if i don't when it comes
to sex
a large portion of that pleasure comes
from
seeing the other person's pleasure if i
am with them
and i'm like dating them like yes
actually like it's the first thing
at my list like she has to finish if
it's like a little hook up like i don't
to my house with you i don't care like i
was more worried about myself i'm not
gonna lie
i am like selfish as soon as it comes to
like hookups when i'm dating you like
i'm making sure that's all i really
really like care about
go ahead you make her bust one time then
two times
one time two times
[Music]
you know that thing nothing that thing
you know but no at the end of the day
yet it's like it's like that you make
her come
once or twice get it out of the way do
it first months if you need two months
no
if you need to if you need some
yamanyama panda boom boom
do that thing and then what is that
actually i'm gonna tell you what i don't
even care if i don't puss
if that's done i could not bust and i'm
good
that's just a preference yeah so if i
agree with what he said in regards to
just taking care of her first because
here's the thing guys we know we can get
ours them getting there is a little bit
more complicated
so just get it out of the way but caveat
here
do not make it too important
and the reason is if you put so much
emphasis on trying to make them get
there
they're going to feel pressure and then
mentally they're going to block
themselves from getting there yeah that
happens with some people
so you know just be like hey do you want
you to feel good if we can get that
great and if we can't that's okay and
you know
don't be like did you come did you come
to tacoma and be like hey listen if you
didn't what do you like maybe we could
work on it and if not don't stress but i
don't want
just reiterate the fact that it's not a
big deal if you do that i promise you
they're gonna feel pretty good about it
uh but yeah just make sure they get
theirs first and then afterwards you can
get yours as many times as you want
because so many dudes have never even
given them theirs
once that if you just give it to them
why is it if you're already
ahead of the game so just take care of
it and then move from there
have you ever questioned your sexuality
absolutely
yeah with that piercing come on with
that piercing
i've been questioning your sexuality 100
for a long time people were like oh yeah
they would assume that i was gay et
cetera and for a while i just
hated that assumption but eventually i
decided to take the time to feel like
hey you know maybe
what if this is the case um and i think
i did my due diligence and like trying
to be honest with myself and recognize
what
was and was not interesting to me and
as such i think i came to a definitive
conclusion i'm definitely
team vagina for sure i'm sorry
i was like what did you did you suck
some dick dick
is that what you're saying i needed to
know i'm saying i sucked a penis and now
i do hey i'm like man not my thing so
yeah
hey live your life bro whatever happens
i did my due diligence you know
took a wiener realized i prefer the bun
got got it was not my thing so i knew
very early on that
i liked that i liked women i i had my
first girlfriend when i well my first
girlfriend when i was in
in first grade i had my first kiss with
the girl when i was in third
yeah no i was it's never something i
questioned yeah
i uh i grew up in a mexican household
so um so latinos uh
they're very be manly and be this and be
that i homophobic what you say bro
and you know like anything that doesn't
involve
whatever typical man is whatever that
means um they were just like no none of
that
i've kissed a man or two
um i think that's maybe the extent of
experimentation
have you ever been self-conscious about
your penis size
hell yeah that's all the guys every dude
every dude watched the porno has been
like
i'm packing but i'm not packing like
that every dude that's every dude that's
normal
every dude they're going to ask
themselves every day at some point
that's everyone especially as a black
male um you know there are a lot of
expectations that are very very very
very lofty you expect to have like
a very large penis mandingo realize that
you don't have them
and so forth bricks
[Music]
are you afraid to draw to try butt stuff
yeah i don't want anyone coming near my
butt what oh
oh my god i did try it
and i didn't like it it was it was
actually the first time i had sex i see
your finger
like going and then i was like oh whoa
she went too far you know what i'm
saying that's your first time you limit
the gooch
the first time you just the fart your
virginity the first time a figure inside
goddamn that's a violation
no nah nah that's a scrap flag on the
plate
yo that's a flagrant foul two
direct ejection get fine 25 000. she
gonna just give it a quick little tap
tap
you know what i'm saying being like
that's a good little butt hole you could
have done something like that
[Music]
you're gonna do a little tap tap but you
can't you can't just stick a finger in
there that's crazy oh what do we have
here yeah that's a good little butthole
look at you with your little dirty ass
you like that that's a good voice yeah
men have been like i mean all of us
really but i'm just speaking to the male
experience a lot of us have been failed
by
sex ed and as a result a lot of us don't
have good education we don't
know what pleasure is like for ourselves
like we know how to get off but we don't
always know what pleasure really feels
like that's how we get better with time
we also don't know what it looks like
for women how to get there how to
accommodate them
um and it's a learning experience man
like how ignorant i was about
everything in my young years was crazy
and my parents coming from a religious
background
certainly weren't going to educate me so
once the school did and i was kind of
just left to my own devices
and so a lot of people are just out here
having sex extremely ignorantly and uh
there's a lot of learning that we have
to do aside it's gonna take some time
though it's gonna take some time
and um just know that just because we're
set because as men were often expected
to push and to do a lot of the action to
do a lot of leading
just because we're in a position to leak
doesn't mean no we know how and it's
just important to know that
even when you had a lot of education
about the thing and we had a lot of
education about sex the way it was
taught to us is that we knew about the
mechanics of the things
yeah so if i teach you all the mechanics
about a car
you're gonna see and you're gonna know
how the car works it doesn't mean you're
gonna know how to drive the thing is
when you're out there knowing the
mechanics of a car but you don't know
the signs you don't know how anxiety
work and you got to learn
all of that and how do you know how if
you get on the road
on the car and you're gonna know
how to drive if they all didn't teach
you about the mechanics on the road
by other people honking and you making
errors
so that's the thing that's a bit
unfortunate and that's why i really like
that video when people
really able to talk about it and
communicate you know i like to have the
woman's perspective on that but that'd
be a good part too better than that
[Music]
why you wanna be a player
i'll be the one that keeps you calm
i